hey 42 here there exists a team of
nuclear physicists engineers and science
fiction writers called the human
interference task force whose sole job
is to find a way to prevent future
humans from stumbling upon our
radioactive waste storage facilities
there is a very real concern that humans
10,000 years in the future might not
understand the warning labels we have
put in place or possibly even our
language thus causing massive harm to
themselves or others by mishandling the
waste this scenario might seem unlikely
but it's much more of a concern than
most people realize in 1987 in Brazil an
incident occurred when the source from a
radiotherapy machine was stolen from an
abandoned Hospital unbeknownst to the
scavengers the object they stole was
extremely radioactive it was covered in
radiation danger symbols but they didn't
recognize them the source was passed
around from person to person resulting
in four deaths from radiation poisoning
and over 250 people were found to have
high levels of radioactive materials in
their bodies luckily the human
interference taskforce have come up with
a solution to the issue of warning
future humans about the dangers of our
radioactive waste ray cuts the idea is
simple genetically modified cats so that
they change color and glow when they are
close to a source of dangerous
radioactivity but there's a step two and
that is to intertwine ray cuts deeply
within the culture of mankind so that
they transcend language building shrines
all over the world - ray cuts on their
radiation divining powers songs have
even been written about breakups the cat
was chosen as an animal because since
the dawn of time it has been a
culturally significant
animal to the human race and should
continue to be so for many thousands of
years the ancient Egyptians worshipped a
cat goddess the only problem we have is
we have yet to find a way to make cats
change color but it is a theoretical
possibility and there are some people
crazy enough out there to give it a shot
now this video has absolutely nothing to
do with cats or radioactivity but that
long segway does allow me to ask a
question that I've long wondered since I
was a small boy how come when
protagonists in superhero films come
into contact of radioactive waste they
get cool superhuman powers whereas in
real life it would only lead to severe
illness and death science fiction
writers have always taken a certain
amount of Liberty was a truth bending
the rules of physics in their writings
but that is their job to do so it is
called science fiction of the raw but
the thing is to be a great science
fiction writer one has to be rather good
at actual science and so sci-fi books
and even films have a scarily accurate
record for predicting the science fact
of tomorrow for the 1964 World's Fair
sci-fi writer Isaac Asimov wrote a paper
making several predictions about life in
the future most of what he predicted was
so accurate that it's almost as if he
owned the TARDIS he says that in 2014 we
will be able to see as well as here who
we are talking to over the telephone he
envisioned large flat-screen televisions
and 3d films he predicted self-driving
cars although he did describe them as
cars with robot brains and he also
predicted the invention of the Internet
but HG Wells also deserves a big mention
for although he was born 150 years ago
in his science fiction novels he
predicted phones
email television lasers atomic weapons
and tanks sure the sci-fi of the past
has also got it grossly wrong got
occasion we still don't have hoverboards
or rehydrated food that Marty McFly
would be proud of but there's no doubt
about it
as time has progressed the line between
science fiction and science fact has
become increasingly blurred I've been
playing a lot of endless space too
recently a new turn-based space strategy
game by amplitude Studios it's an
enthralling space exploration and
colonization game where you can explore
some distant star systems and expand
your space civilization when you chance
upon the ruins of an ancient
civilization you find a powerful
substance called dust which has special
properties and so dust becomes the most
precious and sought-after material in
the universe the intergalactic currency
if you enjoyed endless space and endless
legends then you're going to absolutely
love endless space too it's one of the
most addictive and well crafted games
I've played in a long time if like me
you really enjoy intelligent strategy
games that totally immerse you in
another world then this is just one you
have to play and good news endless space
2 is currently free to play this weekend
only via Steam if you click the link in
a description below what's so great
about endless space 2 is that
everybody's experience is unique to them
every time you play you are immersed in
your own randomly generated galaxy full
of new civilizations life old
technologies and unknown worlds for you
to discover and come
there are limitless possibilities of how
you can play the game so you could truly
put your own mark on the galaxy however
you see fit
endless space twos captivating fictional
universe takes inspiration from sci-fi
literature and movies but also real life
featuring constellations like Auriga or
even more recently the addition within
the game of Trappist one right after the
actual scientific discovery
the idea of intergalactic space settlers
traveling from planet to planet trading
resources waging wars and exchanging
mystical cosmic dust seems most
definitely like science fiction surely
these are no more than fantasies within
a video game but we shouldn't be so
quick to make that assumption
in 2007 Parkes Observatory in Australia
picked up something via their radio
telescope that they've never heard
before
fast bursts of radio waves hitting our
planet each one lasting two milliseconds
but containing incredible amounts of
energy they dubbed this phenomenon an F
R big or fast radio bursts and then
again in 2012 at the Arecibo radio
telescope in Puerto Rico more FR bees
were detected and astronomers have since
been able to pinpoint the exact source
of these mysterious communications from
the depths of space
they didn't originate from our own
galaxy the Milky Way like scientists
originally suspected but from another
galaxy over three billion light-years
away within the constellation of Auriga
since we learnt of their existence we
have only detected a total of 30 F R
bees from outer space the current
scientific consensus is that F our bees
our releases of energy from young
neutron stars all over the universe ie
they are a natural phenomenon but the
FRB that came from the Auriga
constellation
was different of all 30 FRBS we have
detected on earth the Auriga burst is
the only one that has repeated itself f
RB 1 2 1 1 0 2 as it's been
affectionately named repeated itself in
short regular intervals
obviously repetition isn't a quality
often found in nature most of the time
nature appears to be random the power of
this FRP was also off to scale if you
could measure the FRB from all
directions from the source then each
pulse lasting only a few milliseconds
contained more energy than our Sun emits
in a whole year
the unusual and unique nature of this fr
bit led many people both inside and
outside of the scientific community to
theorize that these emissions came from
a highly advanced ancient space
civilisation considering the distance
through the constellation of Auriga and
the power and technology that would be
needed to generate such an immense
signal indicates that if this is true
then the civilization that produced the
FRB would have to be both highly
advanced and very very old sir maybe the
endless space universe as portrayed in
the game series isn't so far from the
truth now the great Douglas Adams wrote
of a species of fish called the babel
fish a small yellow fish that when
inserted into one's ear will
instantaneously translate any language
in the entire universe into the users
native tongue essentially a universal
translator such an incredibly useful
device is not unique to the work of
Douglas Adams an instance universal
translator has been theorized in the
works of many science fiction authors
and filmmakers from Doctor Who to Star
Trek but what if I told you that said
device is no longer the dream of sci-fi
visionaries this year one of the world's
largest tech giant's announced
read of earphones that's are essentially
technological Babel Fish allowing the
seamless translation of over 40 world
languages and you can guarantee that it
won't be long before other large tech
corporations are competing to develop
their own version of the Babel Fish for
consumers in just a couple of years time
global language barriers will no longer
be a barrier at all and that is
astonishing
now teleportation is the most
stereotypical example of science fiction
that one could possibly imagine it has
long seemed an impossibility but even
teleportation is fast becoming a reality
in a recent breakthrough experiment
researchers at the University of Calgary
in Canada managed to teleport a particle
for the first time ever they used the
city's fiber-optic network to teleport a
single photon of light from one side of
the city to the other using a mechanism
known as quantum entanglement a quirk of
quantum mechanics that is so complicated
that even Albert Einstein admitted that
he didn't understand how it works they
were able to transport the particle 3.8
miles at faster than the speed of light
now quantum entanglement can enable
travel faster than the speed of light
because in the world of quantum
mechanics a particle can have a physical
effect on another particle because they
are entangled with one another no matter
the distance between them teleporting a
single particle may not seem like much
but it is the first incredible step in
being able to scale up the process after
all if you can teleport a single
particle it won't be long at all until
we have the capability to teleport
larger objects like caps and toasters
perhaps we could even have teleporting
gray caps that would pop into existence
in a brief flash of glowing hues to warn
you of potential radiation Wow
the future is starting to look we
despite this remarkable achievement
teleporting humans will likely remain in
the realm of science fiction for many
decades but there is a more immediate -
game-changing use for this discovery it
could lead to quantum networking using
the same quantum entanglement methods we
could theoretically create a brand new
global internet network with zero
latency when you send an email or
instant message to a friend in another
country there is a small but noticeable
delay anywhere between twenty to a
thousand milliseconds before it reaches
them this is because the photons of
light that carry the data you just sent
have to physically travel through
fiber-optic cables
possibly across oceans and continents a
quantum internet would be instantaneous
opening a new realm of possibilities for
Internet security medicine military and
many other applications and of course
internet gaming would be an absolute
dream with zero lag but you don't need
to wait for the advent of quantum
networking to experience endless space -
for free this weekend on Steam click the
link in the description to start playing
now thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please click here to
support me on patreon which really helps
our channel click here to watch another
video and if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe